tu che noi conosciamo
il famoso
e monologo di gestita sul balcone
Giulietta cosa si domandava
e domandava Romeo perché tu sei Romeo
Cosa c'è in un nome
perché io non posso amarti soltanto
perché tu ti chiami Capuleti o Scusa il
Montecchi
Giulietta Aveva torto a volte i nomi
servono moltissimo per capire le cose e
servono moltissimo per capire le città
per capire dove viviamo per capire chi
siamo noi abbiamo bisogno anche di nomi
di definizione
per poter
capire
il luogo il territorio che noi
frequentiamo quotidianamente Se io
chiedo
che cosa è una città noi chiamiamo
Rovigo
è una città Certo è una città però anche
New York ed è una città Est e una città
Padova
ma ci sarà bene le differenza tra Rovigo
e New York Rovigo Città del Messico
Eppure noi non abbiamo nomi per questo
Noi oggi come oggi chiamiamo Sempre e
soltanto città qualsiasi luogo anche
Lendinara anche Adria sono città
se Noi invece stiamo più attenti vediamo
come anche dai vecchi toponimi o dagli
nomi che ci ricordano che leggiamo nei
libri
noi vediamo che le città hanno o i
luoghi l'insediamenti nomi diversi
abbiamo un paese un borgo un villaggio
cos'altro ha di una villa
c'è una pesino che si chiama Villa
[Musica]
Grimani mi pare abbiamo altri altri
luoghi il castello Borgo eccetera e si
capisce da questi nomi che noi abbiamo
sul nostro territorio come il
territorio era conosciuto definito e
e coltivato e ricercato anche persino in
inglese ormai non cambia usano sempre lo
stesso nome per qualsiasi luogo adesso
qualsiasi città è una City
il termine ha un non è usato molto ma
molto meno e sulla mente in termini
di parole composte Ora
noi dobbiamo E perché è successo questo
perché noi quello che mi hanno più i
luoghi con un nome specifico
per motivi che adesso cercheremo di
spiegare e che sono veramente gravi
della nostra crisi urbana
abbiamo cancellato noi non abbiamo i
nomi per i luoghi perché abbiamo
cancellato quel rapporto che il
cittadino la persona aveva con il
territorio l'unica zona l'unica area che
è diversa dalle grandi periferie dagli
altri luoghi è praticamente il centro
storico dove bene o male più o meno
Rimangono delle regole di vita diverse
per esempio si va a piedi dei della gran
parte dei centro storici della città non
serve L'automobile
e ci sono ancora tanti piccoli negozi e
una vita diciamo di vicinato
se noi
Ecco se voi pensate facciamo se voi
pensate a Cos'è una città
a me viene in mente il termine latino
della città in latino i romani avevano
due parole per dire città una era Urs
l'urbe L'altra era Civitas da cui deriva
il nome città di adesso Civitas città
che erano due cose diverse che si
fondevano insieme quelle erano due cose
diverse
era l'aspetto materiale della città le
costruzioni Ponti le strade le case le
abitazioni la Civitas era
l'organizzazione l'aspetto sociale
politico L'aspetto della convivenza Ecco
noi oggi usiamo il termine città e
abbiamo idee confuse su cosa vuol dire
città su cosa vuol dire il vivere
urbano e anche questa è un'altra parola
Urbano Cosa vuol dire Urbano Urbano oggi
come oggi
stravolgendo il termine latino Urbano
diventa
tutto quello che ha a che fare con una
certa organizzazione ora Noi viviamo in
un modo tra virgolette Urbano sia che
viviamo in una casa sparsa nel Polesine
o nella Bassa Padovana o in montagna
sia che viviamo al centro di Manhattan
In che senso Noi viviamo in un modo
Urbano bene per il fatto che noi non
consumiamo nulla di quello che
produciamo tutto quello che noi
consumiamo tutto quello che noi mangiamo
che serve per la nostra
riproduzione la nostra
sostentamento è tutto è tutto comperato
un mese fa esattamente come oggi ero a
New York
e vedevo questi milioni di persone che
si muovevano freneticamente per tutta la
città e pensavo tra me e me cosa Cosa
mangia tutta questa gente da dove viene
il cibo che loro mangiano una volta la
gran parte delle persone mangiava quello
che produceva diciamo nell'orto di casa
nella zona
o perlomeno nel quartiere nel paese
o sul territorio oggi tutto quello che
noi consumiamo anche se abitiamo per
così dire in campagna noi comperiamo
tutto quello di cui abbiamo bisogno non
c'è nulla che noi produciamo
In
che produciamo
da noi e consumiamo direttamente
perché questo perché le nostre città il
nostro modo di vivere di
agire nel quotidiano alta ha trasformato
le città e questa è una definizione su
cui mi concentro è quasi uno slogan le
città da luoghi in cui si viveva si
abitava si risiedeva e tutte le parole
anche tecnologicamente hanno un
significato le città dai luoghi in cui
si risiedeva sono diventate si sono
trasformate in
vaste aree in cui ci si muove
continuamente qualsiasi cosa noi
dobbiamo fare
andiamo a farla
non è che noi facciamo vado a fare
Faccio ginnastica no vado a fare
ginnastica vado a fare sport vado a
lavorare no che lavoro faccio c'è sempre
questa idea fondamentale
centrata sul movimento di conseguenza
queste città questi nostro modo di
vivere si è
trasformata da un modo di muoversi e
difatti quando noi parliamo di città
Io quando ero piccola mi chiedevano
Quanti abitanti ha Pavia Io abitavo per
dire E si diceva con molta semplicità
con molta facilità Pavia a 80.000
abitanti
80.20015 una cosa ben precisa ed erano
gli abitanti che erano nel limite della
città e la città finiva con le mura
finiva con un fiume finiva con un limite
ben preciso oggi in tutta Europa in
tutto il mondo di solito quando Voi
chiedete Ma quanti abitanti ha Rovigo
Quanti abitanti a Padova Quanti abitanti
ha Friburgo
Colonia
New York Stoccarda Qual è la risposta
che si dà la risposta unica è sempre e
sola è
il comune di Padova a 200 mila abitanti
l'area metropolitana ne ha
circa 500.000
perché questo perché la città ha perso
l'identità ha perso l'identità la città
piccola ha perso l'identità alla città
grande e le grandi metropoli non li
hanno mai avute sono grandi
espansioni di persone Noi abbiamo avuto
negli ultimi 20 anni
la grande rivoluzione delle delle
comunicazioni e dell'informatica che
vanno insieme perché le informazioni
hanno necessità e sono diventate
diffuse dappertutto grazie alle
telecomunicazioni oggi come oggi a noi
negli ultimi 20 anni ci è sembrato a
tutti di comunque di avere rivoluzionato
la tecnica le chiamiamo ancora alle
nuove tecnologie
quando quando usiamo un iPhone o quando
facciamo una email così o una
videoconferenza ma non sono neanche più
nuove tecnologie prevediamoci conto sono
tecnologie che ormai hanno 20 30 anni io
la mia prima email l'ho scritta dell'89
e ricordo che fu senz'altro un momento
di grande effetto Perché scrivere una
email ma io ricordo anche il primo fax
mi mandarono un fax di Pechino e credo
che sia uno dei momenti più eclatanti
della mia vita pensare che uno infilava
un fax a Pechino arriverà a Padova Vabbè
ma questo parliamo di 35 anni fa il 30
anni fa
queste tecnologie
pare che ci abbiano cambiato la vita è
qualcosa ci hanno cambiato Facciamo meno
fila alla posta facciamo tutto online
eccetera ma il vero cambiamento della
vita urbana non c'è stato Noi viviamo
ancora nelle vecchie strutture sia nelle
vecchie strutture fisiche sia nelle
vecchie strutture mentali La nostra vita
delle città continua ad essere quella
basata sul movimento
vecchia superata che le nuove le
comunicazioni potrebbero
capire siamo diventati la città moderna
o meglio la città post
è
anche per me vale questo non è più la
città vera e propria lapacità post
moderna la città della mobilità da
essere dei
cittadini stanziali che vivevano in un
quartiere vivevano in una zona ben
precisa e siamo diventati dei Nomadi
urbani persone che si muovono
continuamente
il vero problema qual è Di tutto questo
andiamo in una direzione in cui anziché
regredire grazie alle tecnologie alle
nuove tecnologie
verso la capacità la possibilità di
risiedere e di avere tutto vicino casa e
di potere quindi risparmiare
Prima di tutto il tempo della mobilità
se proprio vogliamo essere solo egoisti
ma anche risparmiare in termini di
ambiente per le emissioni del traffico
risparmiare in termini di della
necessità della necessità di possedere
un'automobile
della necessità enorme e devastante di
costruire sempre nuove strade bene tutto
questo si porta ad andare sempre nella
direzione di
aumentare e aumentare sempre di più
questa dipendenza quasi una
tossicodipendenza dalla mobilità dalle
strade dal cemento e non pensate che il
trasporto pubblico sia la soluzione se
noi siamo dipendenti dalla mobilità
e se la mobilità L'automobile è l'eroina
il trasporto pubblico è Il metadone è
cercare di attenuare gli effetti di una
droga della nostra società noi dobbiamo
cominciare a ripensare al rapporto che
noi abbiamo con il nostro territorio con
i luoghi Provate a dare un nome ai
quartieri di Rovigo Provate a dare un
nome
alle
ai luoghi è difficilissimo È uno sforzo
che potremo fare che gli studiosi gli
intellettuali le persone stesse gli
amministratori potrebbero fare però
effettivamente tutta la città
a parte il centro storico diventa
qualcosa di indifferenziato centri
commerciali
centri parcheggi quasi tutti gli uffici
anche voi Adesso avete l'università che
si è
fuori Rovigo è appena sulla
della periferia Per non parlare appunto
dei centri commerciali ma anche per
parlare di tante attività e che rovinano
la città piccola a Padova il centro
storico è stato svuotato di quasi tutte
le attività e questo succede un po'
ovunque anche a Venezia ultimamente si
parlava di spostare il
l'ordine dei giornalisti da campo San
Polo in centro a Mestre perché era più
accessibile e perché questo perché ormai
Stiamo andando in questa direzione se
voi pensate
che questa possa essere la soluzione sia
costruire più strade ampliare le strade
che abbiamo Andiamo nella direzione
sbagliata
città noi seguiamo il modello americano
di avere avuto questo grande
allargarsi della città sparpagliarsi
della città sul territorio sempre più
grandi bene voi pensate che il 70%
della gran parte dei sobborghi di Los
Angeles è costituita
Indovinate da cosa Da strade
Cioè la gente vive sulle strade Los
Angeles è famosa per avere delle
autostrade a 8 corsie io non ho
frequentato molto Los Angeles però ci
sono stato e sono rimasto in colonnato
in autostrade in otto corsie mentre
rimango incolonnato in strade a quattro
a cinque a due a una corsia in qualsiasi
altro posto del mondo non è che
aumentando le corsie tu alla fine riesci
a risolvere i problemi ma perché
facciamo questo perché appena c'è un
problema di traffico
c'è un problema di traffico vuol dire
che c'è troppa gente che vuole andare da
una parte a procurarsi un servizio a
procurarsi qualcosa qual è la soluzione
che subito ci viene in mente facciamo
una strada
il più illuminati credono di dire
facciamo trasporto pubblico ma non serve
facciamo una strada aumentiamo questo no
quello dovrebbe essere la risposta la
risposta intelligente la risposta
avanzata tecnologicamente matura Grazie
alle nuove tecnologie che non sono più
nuove grazie a una forma del pensiero la
risposta sarebbe riportiamo
gran parte dei servizi riportiamo le
cose di cui abbiamo bisogno vicino a
casa nostra Negli anni cinquanta fino
agli anni 50-60 ogni scuola elementare
doveva essere raggiungibile a piedi da
un bambino in 20/30 minuti e c'erano
tantissime scuole elementari con una
maestra con una classe perché tutti
dovevano avere tutto il più possibile
nella loro zona ora Questo è già molto
più possibile di una volta
la trasformazione è stata invece
qual è stata la grande trasformazione il
grande genialità degli urbanisti
costruire le città studio dove accorpano
tutti gli istituti che si chiamano
comprensibili e comprensivi non perché
tutti sono promossi ma comprensivi
perché ci si mette dentro di tutto bene
lo stesso fanno per gli ospedali
concentrazione di tutto Mentre noi
dobbiamo ripensare a questo concetto a
questo concetto che è
riportiamo i cittadini là dove
ci sono i servizi riportiamo i servizi
laddove ci sono i cittadini
Grazie
[Applauso]